[Applaudissements]
et au bout
alors on a mis un beau cuir de vachette
fait plaisir c'est mon plus beau il est
magnifique et là normalement on l'achète
en turquie au club med ya toujours un
magasin dans le mail frère tu mets de
une paire de babouches et des biens mais
il est très beau c'est qu'il est très
bon c'est vrai il s'intitule adore ben
je mets souvent il est bon mais j'en ai
pas 40 en même temps
quoi il ya une odeur ou pas alors bon je
vais te dire qu'elle l'a perdu le cerf
au début j'ai depuis très longtemps
l'honneur a disparu il ya plus de 9000 à
la presse que c'est vrai que quand on va
dans des boutiques aux cures qui
s'avèrent de cuir faire un bonne année
mais sans y était persuadé que le
blouson pue de la gueule mais ça a été
tu étais blouson plus de la bouche quoi
saint-bruno voie ferrée teinte a
remarqué mais c'est un truc de fou je te
jure là ça va
mieux on va d info on a des nouvelles de
britney chiche oui britney spears away
alors ça c'est l'instinct de la semaine
parce que je vais essayer chaque semaine
un petit peu de raconter une petite
histoire à partir d'un stade g britney
spears elle est encore en roue libre sur
un stade elle a 42 millions de personnes
qui de la suivre il faut savoir que ces
schistes ont accusé ya pas longtemps
justement de se mettre à poil tout le
temps d'être d'en faire trop alors il a
voulu leur souhaiter un joyeux
anniversaire sur un style qu'un petit
post mignon une photo d'elle avec ses
fils etc sauf que trois jours par mois
si ble ment elle avait pas
voilà c'est cette photo aurait trouvé la
voie parce que c'est bon ces deux jours
avant de leur poser un petit message en
fait c'est un rembrandt
[Rires]
donc voilà donc en 48 heures elle
souhaite un joyeux anniversaire à ses
ficelles poste ça je pense que ses
filles sont pas forcément apprécié parce
qu'elle a supprimé le poste 1 ouais a
saisi ses seins britney est la poste il
n'y avait pas le coeur en fête
maintenant elle a mis un petit coeur sur
la tirelire histoire ça reste quand même
un accord
et s'arrêter reliant la place
sachez que daniel moreau n'a pas
beaucoup d'autres
non mais attention attirée mais elle s
est pas de noirs
desseins à gauche soit les bouches des
saint louis c'est pas moi je vois une
lampe alors on n'a pas les même
pas les mêmes priorités suis désolé
géraldine maillet alors messieurs et
ouais je dis est la raison franchement
ça fait la même toit
avoir un tableau chez toi
je crois bien là même la semaine
prochaine maintenant je veux pas faire
peur mais honnêtement si j'étais gaulé
comme ça mais j'en prenais trop lent
mais attention britney
je m'apprête voulez je vous dise la
vérité je pense en plus je suis sûr et
certain c'est parce que je peux la pécho
pas venu à
paris oui je suis sûr et certain que
britney si je lâche et branché sur comme
la pêche ou mais les musicales non mais
bon pour le fun
se marier mais justement sérieux elle a
fêté ses deux semaines de maria bayo va
dans trois semaines c'est fini
non il faut plus la pêche au liban
tu vois là non mettez moi plutôt de mecs
de daniel moreau non nasa vient de se
marier non mais c'est pas mon délire en
plus nombreux mais cela est bien j'adore
ça pour rigoler c'était pour le lap ou
quoi et moi je pense d'abord téloche
kouao les mères voilées messi alors donc
si on lui parle plus bas en fait c'était
pour faire un rapprochement qui
visiblement n'a pas fonctionné parce
qu'elle a supprimé le poste quelques
jours après qu'ils étaient destinés à
ses enfants donc elle les voit plus on
le sait ça fait un bon nom et ils n'ont
pas très envie de la revoir ah ouais et
on comprend pas ce que la photo qu'on a
vu ce soir qu'il ya 40 millions de
personnes à l'avoir à chaque fois donc
c'est un peu complexe qui fait un post
pour ces enfants qu'une eu comme sahin
ses rêves - la mère l'a fait la semaine
la nage pas dans
la merde on y sert internet mais
franchement clément je dis rien toi
maintenant moi je n'ai pas une pièce
dans la tirelire et puis j'ai envie de
vous dire que pourquoi les est pourquoi
nous faut pas le nier mais fans sous une
mine plutôt que de médecins sur
instagram je touche au toit
se sont toujours
d'avis devant d'année le volant
ces récits vainqueur grady frais
seraient bannis à moi je le fais
pour
web et d'haïti pourrait le faire toi
chemin tupperwares
ça dépend ce matin jean
louis alors franchement ouais parce que
c'est artistique seront très très bas
fait le la semaine prochaine
[Applaudissements]
castaldi sur ma vie je le regarde frère
il a des yeux de plus en plus petite
de regarder la balle c'est un truc de
fou en direct et un gars qui arrivent
c'est parce que t'es pas encore émis je
suis très habillé son bord avait laissé
mes yeux c'est comme ça non hier ils
étaient plus ouverts c'est de se fermer
à la fin de la semaine
[Rires]
je voulais faire la photo ouais mais là
j'ai la poitrine un peu à gauche c'est
pas mal ça évite à lui il a les fesses
tout lisse
moi j'ai vu une très bonne par contre de
très très très bref dans le nid c'est
pour voir ça peut poser d'ailleurs
bouffe s annonce était balancé en pleine
crise et a bouclé ce genre de photos ça
vous titille revoici maxima must est ce
un vrai bon chemin et bon et voient
comme leur faudrait placer sur instagram
mais si c'est sur papier glacé par une
photo de mannequin si oui vous voyez
comme tom kim kardashian de soutien
à la une d'un magazine ou d'envoi la
voyez ce que je veux dire non non non
non bon et si elle vous l'envoie vous en
priver oui oui je me rejoindre quel
espace passives
sont merde pas avec ça ok flo ouais on a
un projet poursuit wizarbox cuse moi te
parlé
à leonardo dicaprio il a une nouvelle
fois c'est la rumeur de la semaine en
fait il a une à une nouvelle bombe
atomique à son tableau de chasse mais il
aurait aimé on pense t-il à elle
s'appelle j j a dit baala bob de
leonardo non c'est pas la mort de justin
ont
mis la main de personne non c'est un
mode de personnes à la rue des halles a
eu des mecs elle a été en couple etc
elle a une petite fille de deux ans et
c'est donc elle a un passé j j a dit
amoureux je connais j'y allais son père
rené haby
alors ils seraient ensemble ils avaient
la rumeur qui courait depuis un moment
ils ont été paralysés par un particulier
une petite photo secrète faite avec un
téléphone très récemment et les médias
américains et anglo-saxons la voit ici à
l'écran notamment le daily mail ont
plein d'infos et soi-disant leur
rapprochement le 25 en 27 ans
j'ai passé là c'est la petite
originalité ces cas-là 27 ans saïd les
vides
[Rires]
la plupart les ex en 25 ans est vrai
dernier la raison pourrait faire le club
des 25 parce que c'est vraiment il ya
une date de péremption pour lui sauf
qu'elle a une petite soeur qui s'appelle
bella qui est aussi belle qu'elle
qu'elle est mannequin également elle
répond au nom de bella et bien pas tout
n'est pas tout le temps mais en général
oui et à la 25 ans ah ouais ok un peu
plus jeune donc attention si un vrai
rapproche des intrus fracasse méfie de
sa petite soeur 1 est d'accord ce que ça
peut être compliqué j'essaie toujours
les mêmes afin dé blonde aux yeux bleus
toujours pas arrêt daniel méfie toi ça
va arriver ça va tomber sur la niaque à
ses chances avec indication
sur qui pourrait être pécho bien sûr un
bébé ouais je préfère toi
et bouffe dire un petit malabar je te
crever
comme ça que je touchais très près votre
[Rires]
choix quoi qu'est ce qui fait notre
choix entre nous deux par exemple alors
ne mettez pas dans le
sas et de la laisser comme benhaim we
are my way alors on a une dernière info
bon allez là c'est un ami donc là je ne
sais pas si si je dois donner ou pas bah
on la raconte quand même alors passe
normalement c'est un ami donc ses
passions la raconte ou pas ah qu'est ce
qu'on fait
raconte alors je vais sortir matériel ah
ouais je sors vous faites la séquence on
voit comment ça roule sans vous ouais et
si je reviens pas c'est que
malheureusement personne ne viendra non
je sors je dois bien j'y vais je démarre
alors je vais vous parler d'un
la série s'appelle donc jarry jarry
animateurs que l'on connaît et humoriste
également et qui est selon nos amis
public 1 finalement un peu problématique
faut pas se fier à la houppette tu vois
et au sourire et à la bonne humeur etc
il est visiblement un peu plus compliqué
dans public et un article qui raconte
cette semaine on le découvre ensemble il
ya une source qui dit qu'il est très
très très difficile à vivre la personne
n'en peut plus apparemment il s'est
disputé avec toute l'équipe sur le big
show l'émission sur laquelle
est pas mon avis je vous parle d'un
article n'était plus anciens amis de
cyril je sais je sais voilà c'est ce qui
est dit moi j'ai passé quelques coups de
fil depuis c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
problèmes sur matt singer notamment j'ai
eu un producteur au téléphone qui m'a
dit que ça avait été un peu compliqué de
travailler avec lui
ça a été très compliqué voilà je sais
pas si certains d'entre vous le
connaissent un petit peu s'il ya des
petits conflits s'ils existent qu'on
peut paraître vous dire pourquoi aller
que j'arrive juste ils exigent et je
vous dire ils ont mis dans deux
émissions qui sont catastrophiques
absolument le big show c'est de la merde
max singer n'a même pas vous dire je
vous résumer l'histoire qu'il a il
arrivé ici qu'est ce que c'est que cette
merde il est pas producteur des trucs le
bit chaussée ni fait ni à faire c'est
encore notre amie alexandra wright la
directrice des divertissements signé sa
fille et trois numéros de nom mais les
médecins sont elles plus ça marche pas
plus ou moins de helsinn suis pas tout à
fait voilà non mais voilà elle sait
voilà je vais vous dire c'est pas le
couteau de plus aiguisé du tiroir
donc voilà donc elle signe que des
merdes donc lui un moment il agira sous
x avec tf1 c'est pas pour faire que des
merdes voilà et en plus ce qu'on trouve
dans ma stinger c'est quand même
l'émission la plus triste du paf donc
voilà donc le pot je comprends déjà ric
rac et jarry continue à craquer et voilà
que tu as bien raison
il a raison de faire de la merde le big
show de toi tu devrais faire le big show
c'est un choix fait
j'étais garé il est jeune il est beau
gosse alors juste de petites infos sur
jarry a contrario de l'article de public
que je connais bien
il a deux nouvelles émissions sur france
2 qui vont arriver rendez vous chez
jarry le dimanche après midi ça va être
une sorte de comment ça va bien de
stéphane bern où il va parler brico déco
etc et une autre encore c'est un format
et un autre cinq formats belge qui amène
j qui s'appelle tabou et en france ça va
s'appeler qui osera le dire c'est un
format qui était proposé à nagui en
prime time il a refusé et ça sera le
samedi après midi donc la pire qu'a ce
qui existe je pense que c'est le samedi
après midi et le concept est très simple
c'est tout ce qu'on ne peut pas dire ils
vont le dire et tout ce qu'on ne peut
pas faire ils vont le faire donc ça va
être la folie surtout sur france 2 6 sur
un voilà ce qu'est ce qu'on peut pas
faire et je dis merde
[Rires]
c'est grâce à mes yeux on dira
certainement saperlipopette
naissant et quand il les connaît et sur
france 2 frères les rebelles de france
deux frères hier c'est une barque à
total le pauvre jarry jarry et des
arêtes a vécu arrête je te dis la vérité
à rex perrotta du talent en quoi mes
nuits des rillieux déroule le tapis
rouge il envoie dans le mur frère parce
que tu crois quoi que je dise comment ça
se passe avec les animateurs il leur
donne beaucoup beaucoup de choses au
début et pas prêts ils prennent une fois
le mur deux fois le mur trois fois mieux
qu'à un moment ils sont en réunion
j'arrive pas ou feint mais marc jarry
pas ou que tu le regardes tu là ne l'est
que des merdes série on est sur le
service public quand même je me suis
renseigné est ce que vous savez combien
coûte un numéro du big show huit cent
mille sept cent cinquante pays je sais
sur le service public c'est pour faire
des quatre cantons les ménagères alors
que le but est de rajeunir la case du
samedi 7 et sont finies dernier
ménagères derrière même france 3 voilà
c'est quand à se faire mais rien qui
avait nommé je vais vous dire tant
qu'ils ont et je le dis je suis dit sous
le choc hic c'est qu'ils étaient nuls
voilà la règle soit gentil
je lui ai dit je lui ai dit je voulais
que je dis ce que je vais lui envoyer la
télévision est un métier malheureusement
ce n'est pas le tien c'est votre premier
essai c'est ton ami nous a répondu du
coup le monde amis mais ça ne regarde
personne me répond
les gens ne répond plus
ça me rappelle plus si vous étiez avec
elle pourtant là oui oui non ah oui
alors vous entendez bien on va dire
alors faut arrêter venu à la maison et
il
a de la chance elle
oui mais je pensais qu'il allait me
donner deux trois programmes
[Applaudissements]
elle est amie avec ma femme voilà donc
ses amis et demi et qu'on mecs comme non
franchement voilà elles sont très très
copines les deux phases et des copines
non je suis pas super ciel se parlent
encore là mais bon ça on s'en fout mais
je voulais accueillis à la maison vers l
barbotaient dans la piscine
le bar beauté après un déjeuner avec des
cantons et directrice du divertissement
n'a pas une obligation de résultat
reuters il ne fonctionne pas lui va
dégager et elles n'ont pas énormément
bon ça va arriver un moment un moment je
vous dirai ça fait plusieurs années que
les
annales mais je l'adoré j'adore j'adore
tout le monde sait les stéphane sitbon
gomez incroyable car le giga note or
lingen carling got to buy 60 ans qui a
remis ça en même temps
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent je vais aller à
feu a contrario de vous c'est votre ami
mais moi j'ai trouvé que quand il
animait c'était pas bon à josette
évident le big show j'ai trouvé qu'il
incarnait pas le qui se démenaient en
vain il courait partout mais y'avait
rien
j'ai trouvé qu'il était bon animateur
déchiré